so before getting into detail in to the
various Quantum Technologies past and
present and future I think it's
important for all of us to be able to be
on the same footing regarding what
Quantum effects are behind them and
really kind of have a thorough uh sort
of list of of all these con effects that
really I think at this point everybody
should know about because they're really
kind of prominent in many of the
technologies that we already use so
here's the four quantum effects for the
layperson
the first is probably one that everybody
already knows about because it's almost
something that defines quantum mechanics
and and your first conversations about
it
and that's discreetness
of quantum States or discreteness of
energies of quantum States
and it basically just says that a
Quantum State a uh that that you uh can
pick from does not occupy arbitrary
energy uh you can only have a set of
states that occupy certain quantized or
discrete energies the word Quantum even
comes from this one simple system that
we can demonstrate this with is called a
particle in a box there's some box here
there's some position X here that we can
denote and
um this is very similar the states of
the system are very similar to the
slinky that Professor Moriarty and his
monkey were dangling next to the wall
and uh if you imagine you know a slinky
you can sort of drive it to to have to
be in a standing wave with with no nodes
uh you can have it be in a way with one
node
you can have it be in a way with
two nodes Etc
and the energies of this
are one two and four for this Quantum
system
and the point is that here the energies
are indeed quantized was there a reason
why you've got energy levels one two and
four no three a particle in a box its
energies are um the energy is
proportional to the square of the number
energy is proportional to N squared
where n is the number now when uh do we
see this do we see this in the real
world are my hand positions quantized is
your uh mashed potatoes in the microwave
kind of quantized temperatures uh when
you measure the temperature not really
you need to see uh you need to have for
the most part uh small and a cold system
to be able to start to see or resolve
these different energies because they
come you know sometimes the unit of
quantization is pretty small so this is
maybe it's at first seems really strange
because in our world we're at such
coarse grained scales and there's so
much energy around us that uh you know
we don't really see any of this
minuscule microscopic quantization but
it's definitely there and it's extremely
precise namely that we use this this
quantization of energies to determine
many of our fundamental constants we've
been doing that for a while now
so we're basically it's all basically
certain that all of this is kind of
there if you know where to look so for a
Quantum system uh you know going forward
you you want to just uh have some system
of writing these states and denoting
their Quantum and what we do is we put
them in a cat so this is called a cat
and inside the cat we put in the picture
or some symbol or a number denoting
which state we're talking about here so
we're talking about here the the no note
state so I'll just draw a picture of the
no note State same here here's the cut
for that one and then there's another
cat for this one
and uh you know these is the stuff
inside these cats can be whatever you
want to denote the quantum system it
could be a cat that's alive or dead you
know the famous example it can be some
real number Etc it can be a binary
string a string of zeros and ones to
denote the state of a state of qubits of
a quantum computer even though the the
set of States occupy discrete specific
energies that are spaced apart in some
energy difference that's very precise
there can still be infinitely many of
them and as you can see here you know
this is no node one node two node three
node Etc so Quantum systems can be an
arbitrarily high energy states but you
know as you crank up the energy you get
you lose a lot of the control and so
it's so so for the most Technologies we
really use just a few low-lying energy
states and the simplest case is just two
states
hence the name Cubit the second
principle is the principle of
superposition and collapse
this to me is probably the weirdest one
even though this is something that you
also see in wave Mechanics for example
uh
dropping pebbles in a pond
you have some fixed types of waves that
you have in the pond and if you drop
multiple Pebbles you can these these
waves will interfere or super pose with
each other similarly the states of this
Quantum system that I have say this no
node in this one node State can be in
Quantum superposition with each other
now what's different
um between the superposition of waves in
a pond from say one Pebble and another
pebble
and this Quantum superposition well two
things
for one
um
there's a source of intrinsic Randomness
here so we really don't know which state
that this this system is in
let's say why is this intrinsic well let
me compare this to ordinary Randomness
let's say I flip a coin and I put it
down on my hand and I don't show it to
you so you don't know what the outcome
is the coin is as it heads is it Tails
um
and uh does that mean that to you the
coin is in Quantum superposition no
because somebody knows let's say I look
I know but even if I don't look the skin
on my hand knows whether it's touching
the heads or the tail side of the coin
so this state of the system has been
predetermined you just happen to not
know it the tree's already fallen in the
woods uh you know it made a sound you
just didn't hear it
uh the difference here is that this
isn't truly a Quantum superposition
namely nobody knows where which state
this is in and the second part that's
different is that you change the state
by looking at it so the principle of
collapse here says that if you say look
at it
look at the state
you will project onto some set of states
with some probabilities
associated with them and this will be
intrinsically random you don't know the
outcome of priori and once you look at
it it'll immediately collapse to one or
the other outcome let's say here just as
an example I can collapse to this state
with 50 probability and to this day with
50 probability now if I go back to my
pebbles in the pond and throw a bunch of
pebbles in a pond and I look at them the
the waves could care less if I'm looking
at them or not so there's going to be no
collapse happening so the wave mechanics
part is the same however there is
something that that happens when you
look at the system and the the what you
get is intrinsically a random outcome
and as you may suspect uh this intrinsic
Randomness that's uh that's true for
Quant that happens in Quantum systems
can be used to generate uh certified
random numbers which is one application
of this principle another application
you can maybe infer is is trying to do
you know computation in parallel because
you have the ability to generate a state
that has multiple different components
in it however this is kind of misleading
because it's not as powerful as you
might think and the reason being here is
that yes you can generate superpositions
in that sense there's some
parallelization but you get to look at
these things and they immediately
collapse ruining their for ruining the
superposition
and uh
even though you can look at them and
from from all sides and directions and
in diff you can perform different types
of quantum measurements you still only
get a a One-Shot look at partially what
the state is so you have to look at it
in multiple times from say many
different directions to really get a
feel for what the state is and so it's
not like you have this bona fide state
that you can really you know observe
there's a live superposition so the the
principle of parallelization here is not
quite the right analogy third principle
is uncertainty and here I can
demonstrate it uh using the ingredients
we have in our Quantum system
and I want to immediately say that this
is also principle that you see or hear
more uh precisely in when you hear a
classical music concert or any music
concert and this just uh has to do with
the fact that uh being precise in one uh
uh variable or parameter uh comes at the
expense or price of being imprecise in
another let's use our ingredients here
for our for our particle in a box and uh
the two parameters we're interested in
are frequency and position I'm going to
measure these things and uh how come I
can use the word frequency here well
because if I let's say start with a
super high energy state that has lots of
these nodes here
uh then uh this state that almost fills
up the well
and I'm trying to make these all look
the same so pardon the artistic
rendition
the these um
these types of high energy states they
they basically start to look like waves
for high enough energy especially if you
ignore the ends of the box or make the
Box really big really wide so when they
start to look like waves then they begin
to gain a notion of frequency and you
can see that if you fit a lot of
repetitions of this of this wave in here
for in for a high frequency this can
happen for a fixed size of the well then
you can see that you can more or less
discern the frequency with relative
certainty now conversely if you were to
try to look at where the position of the
particle is remember
the position here is
X for us so where where where is this
particle can we pin it down to a precise
position by looking at it in a way that
measures the collapses it onto a
position well then we would be more or
less uniformly distributed our guess is
to where this particle will be if we
look at it is is more or less uniform we
don't it's kind of all spread out all
over the well and in that sense this
particle doesn't have a very precise
position when it is in this high energy
state
so relative to the frequency that we can
already see by just looking at the
studying the the wave function here the
position can is is less certain of this
particle okay now let's look at the sort
of the converse State or the closest
counter example to this type of behavior
by looking at the ground state the one
with no nodes
and uh here uh if you even consider
thinking of it as a wave which you know
you don't even have a single wavelength
fit in here you have half a wavelength
fit in here so because you don't have a
lot of repetition you can't really
discern any repetitive behavior and so
any notion of frequency here
is very much less
certain
conversely
if you were to try to guess you know
pick a pick some range of numbers where
this position would be in contrast to
this case where this it's very
delocalized here you know it's it's more
or less Dr kind of focused on the center
and it tends to ignore you know it
doesn't like being near the ends as much
as it does near the center now granted
this is not as sharply as sharply peaked
as I would like in this analogy but it's
sort of the ingredient we have for this
specific system so I don't want to make
things more complicated by drawing
something that we don't have out of
these although in principle it's
possible to engineer something like that
by superposing a bunch of these and
there are videos on Fourier analysis
that you can you know look a number file
and um
so now if we look at this position right
the it kind of tries to avoid the ends a
little bit and so you can say that
relative to you know having any notion
of frequency it definitely has a clearer
notion of uh position so what is the
point here well the point is that you
can create states of quantum systems
that are more precise uh have more
precisely determinable values of one
parameter at the price of being less
precise in another parameter
and this is useful for sensing Quantum
or Quantum sensing or Quantum Metrology
or Quantum Imaging because creating a
state that has a very precisely centered
and a sharp distribution of one
parameter allows you to sense shifts in
that parameter very nicely let's say I
wanted to sense the kicks in position
say I have some probe that that kicks my
particle a little bit changes its
position which state would I want to use
well I want to use the state that a
priori has an as a well-defined position
to begin with so that when there's a
small shift the position for
sufficiently small shift will also
remain more or less uh you know focused
and we'll be able to measure it
precisely just by looking at the
position if we if we're trying to kick a
position of a state whose position is
smeared on all over the well that's not
going to work and what's interesting is
that this sort of total uncertainty
between one variable and another is
constant and so you can smear it around
you can you can make one variable more
precise at the expense of making the
other one less precise and this is
something that uh people have utilized
in detection of gravitational waves the
fourth effect is entanglement and this
is
something that
there's also misconceptions about but
it's not really nothing but the upgrade
of the superposition principle to
multiple systems multiple Quantum
systems so far I've looked at one
Quantum system and I've showed you that
has different states but now let's
consider we have you know two systems or
two particles
and we want to
study
what states they have well to draw a cat
of two particles we need to have some
way of denoting which state the first
one is in and which state the second one
is in so we need to have basically
comma separated symbols and let's say we
have some uh the state of the first
system or first particle is in the no
node State and the state of the second
one is in this one note State and now to
demonstrate entanglement we just apply
the principle of superposition and just
superpose it with another two body State
let's say now where things are the
opposite you have the first system in
the one node State and second in the no
node state so this is an entangled State
and what is entangled about it well the
point is here that the two particles are
following some rule which leads to them
being correlated in a way so what is
this rule well the rule is that if you
have two states they can be in
uh but if one of them is in one of the
States the no note State the other one
automatically is not in the no node
state which means it's in the other
state the one note state likewise if the
first particle is in the OneNote State
the other one second particle is in the
no note State because it cannot be in
the one node state
so
this type of rule makes these particles
correlated in this way and because these
are in Quantum superposition this
correlation is intrinsically Quantum and
this is what's called entanglement the
rule though is something that again you
see in classical physics because the
rule is something that I can show
demonstrate using socks if I promise you
that I wear opposite colored socks red
and blue then if you see a red sock on
my right foot then you're going to see a
blue sock on the on the left foot and
there's nothing spooky about that or
anything it's just in setup by the rule
by the sort of the the type of state
that I'm looking at here so what's cool
about the quantum version of this is
that you can infer the state of the
other system just by looking at the
first system because of this rule if I
Collapse the first state
in this way onto one of these other or
the other uh uh you know no node or one
node State I will uh be able to infer
what state the other system is in if I
get the no node outcome for the collapse
of the first system I know the other one
will be in the one note state it doesn't
matter how far separated these are the
rule has apriori determined the
correlation that they're going to have
and it's only up to now the collapse
principle to figure out which one of
these States they're in
and uh this uh powerful uh notion of
quantum correlations or entanglement is
useful uh for uh Quantum Computing and
uh while it's pretty simple for two
systems uh as we scale it up for n being
greater than 2 3 4 Etc uh this gets
pretty complicated and it's really
because for two states per system you
have two to the N States for n systems
and meaning that the number of states
doubles every time you add one more
particle and you have a nice video about
that demonstrating that and the
usefulness of that in Quantum Computing
because each qubit itself is doubling so
you have to think of that number of
doublings each time these are basically
the four quantum effects the hope is
really that everybody will will know
them because they're really been
utilized for Metrology uh being utilized
now for computing utilized for
gravitational waves MRI lasers Etc but
really all four are necessary for modern
Quantum Technologies
is a superposition of waves on that
string this string can be in a range of
different types variety of different
types of modes of oscillation waves of
vibrator written it onto this file but
it's left the rest of this file intact
because it's not truncated the file so
if I take a different